house comrades for my name is maja you
know my [ __ ] name [ __ ]
all right we're playing stowaway whoa I
can pick stuff up look yeah I'm [ __ ]
he-man we got a lighter we got a bunch
of stuff I consume that's kind of cool
this game actually looks pretty [ __ ]
cool all right we're good we're good
we are dead all right so we have like
CCTV
that's kind of cool my god ii see stuff
this is spooky man out of like this
hello I guess I'm going down there huh
oh god don't hit me
damnit what is happening I don't like
this mom shut up how do I open this door
there we go that was easy
hello what okay what was that
oh no we're fine ah [ __ ] yo [ __ ] why do
you do that
Jesus Christ
well there's a shadow there isn't it
Oh who's there woohoo who's there oh god
oh god I'm so dead alright let's go up
here someone cry
Amy find a handle I need to [ __ ]
learn how to handle this [ __ ] that's
what I need all right hello damn senpai
one of them has escaped [ __ ] hello oh
god oh god oh god okay oh god oh god I'm
dead hello there was someone in that
corridor [ __ ] me senpai alright we're
still alive we can still do this let's
go down here cuz it's not creepy at all
chains hello
well [ __ ] you no no no no no no no no no
no someone burp what die slide why would
you be such a [ __ ] damn it what is
happening in this boat how did I get
here I want to go home to mom I got
gloves now it's fine I have a flashlight
now nice all right what do i do then ah
[ __ ] me hello Beth there Jesus why do
you have to do loud noises it's like my
biggest weakness in my entire life
all right you know what I'm gonna go
here you can't [ __ ] me I'll [ __ ] you no
no one would
Jesus Jesus nothing nothing will happen
what happened what is going on what is
happening what is that all right great
we're still alive I don't care as long
as we're alive I don't care look why
don't I wear this this is beautiful and
that mask that looks pretty badass I
gotta say I got it Oh a note give it to
me baby s s one out of seven ss well I
could just make them myself they're not
that hard in intricate to make
open open I say simp i simpiy don't
thank you
[ __ ] sake man
all right CCTV all right what do we got
there's a box there that blinks what
else I don't see anything oh god no
another T well so far so good I would
sight
there we go this is going great press
proud of you come on guys you need to
chill did it did it character did it did
it did did it did it it it it it it it
it along I crouched a change in please
there you are this is where we were
before
now we have the toolbox I don't think
they liked that I got it though but it
will make it out alive Abra's don't you
worry babe don't oh god you scared me
what do we go now though we have the
toolbox yeah now we have the handle now
we can handle [ __ ] ha ha a beast you
okay what rude oh come on you attention
[ __ ]
ah faked i loved-ed hand bet that
goddamn life
life boy who's in charge of the security
of this damp forsaken place come on
Vince really really don't fall down we
can do this come on some pie this is not
funny
senpai hello okay I got my lighter
what oh [ __ ] my ass out come on
now what stop why is everything breaking
as soon as I go near it
what'd I do to deserve this nothing
I've been genuinely nice for Dad oh come
on
God well I guess this is my stop all
right oh so far so good right right oh
nice
hello hand could you give me a head Wow
all right where's that hand
let's [ __ ] waltz in here shut up
no [ __ ] way alright well I left the
Vlad up some steam oh shut up wolf I
wouldn't take the batteries okay so I
find the flashlight I found the tool bar
and i regulate develop pressure what
else do I need to do like some pie what
do you want from me don't let him out
don't tell me what to do
[ __ ] well I guess we go home chip
cheerio it's been great
hello hand
I don't like this noises I don't like it
one bad but sometimes in life yes
batteries where the Marling's gone and
you can't go on batteries when you wear
a thong anyone be long a batteries
what's going on here a box and blood ha
I think I ought God what are you doing
there
Hey look I got it [ __ ] Jesus get alive
what am I going oh
control the courage cool thank you
it's pretty pretty I would say hello
it's pretty stuff going on here over
here now
no wait at I'm sure no oh oh I thought I
heard footsteps that scared the [ __ ] out
of me Oh God
Oh God uh that ammonition no it's a
chair damn it I always mix those two up
I can't I can't do chasing stuff
[ __ ] me senpai that's not nice where am
I
okay I found the handle finally gosh
darn it
[ __ ] [ __ ] see I'm not even scared
of you anymore
become a [ __ ] well you're absolutely
right all right well I guess we keep
going that it is this is where we need
all my god I actually found it what the
[ __ ]
alright well that was nice what now
well so far so [ __ ] amazing I would
say pick up the fish like whoa nice
jumper just want to get the there we go
so much easier now
where are we there's something shiny
here hey
all right we got the a all right well I
guess we go up ah yes we don't go up
then [ __ ] sorry didn't know you were
such a [ __ ]
hello we're clear we're good
don't worry bro ChaCha's don't be scared
it's just a game I love you it's gonna
be alright it's gonna be okay
this is me slapping ten pies for day
look I got goose bumps like a freaking
[ __ ] that was good I was a good scare I
like it I like it a lot it was very
funky it made me feel weird in the right
places and I think that's how you know
you've been doing great you can support
this game on Kickstarter
that's rad it's pretty cool support
their Kickstarter why not
thanks for liking this video browse and
as always stay awesome bros